[Applause] blassic getss it going the right
direction as Sturm fires it in that's Bailey
on the far side for San Jose turned over back
to the net they [Applause] score let's take
another look you're right I think you're right
it might have been Kevin leank hurdle now deep
to declair and up for granin the pass to the
wing eckan zerin back for William eckan gramlin
pumps it and and they score toas hurdle and
it's a one goal game four to three and now
the aitor looking to clear but it's clumped down
by zland he gets it back down the boards baraban
drops for eckan shoots they score hurdle for the
hattick and wor look at ekan freze soken looks
like he's shooting to the net finds hurdle
sliding into that quiet are area sharks are
tight it up and as you said wow granin got to
go he'll come to center 8 seconds to go granin
in eand shoots and scores William Eckland wins
it in overtime what a comeback by the [Music]
sharks they are stunned here on Long Island
and the Sharks all celebrate their biggest
win of the year and everybody is Happy cppo
gets the celebration after a period they were
reeling foret here's as the Sharks come ahead
short-handed hurdle with eckan hurdle shoots
and [Applause] scores still some work to
do here though on this penalty kill broken
up and Ruda will clear it ahead and now a foot
race and a breakaway nland in alone scores two
short-handed goals on the same penalty kill and
it's 42 Kane to the outside against a Hut now
blastic out of the box and Burrows will send
it ahead for blasic he's got it with sturs he
scor three in a row and it's 43 unbelievable here
in Detroit as Nico Sturm brings the Sharks back
to within one it's been tough keeping track
here granin or make it leank with Sturm two
on one Bailey stirred go they've come back from
4 nothing down in the same period it's tied and
Sturm has two in a row and this is absolutely
incredible I I I can't remember Randy a period
like this ever in all our years together with the
sharks this is a period of legendary performance
worked his way up from D3 gender into a pretty
darn good career granin loads up fires it off the
boards they score it's hurdle and it's tied again
rayan looking for wman who opens up to take the
pass Raymond off his back foot and now a foot race
and here's zerland in alone on the Breakaway grin
scor they did it again the sharks with an
unbelievable comeback and then the overtime
winner here in Detroit as Larin trying to
come back here he just loses his balance
they knock skates and down they go then he
holds the stick and that's a terrific fake
by zerland Across the grandland it's just
hustle it's just checking it's skating off
the puck it's working for the puck it's
never stopped working and that's what
the Sharks did all night tonight and they
get two wins in a row it's it's and in a
really amazing entertaining fun hockey game
who's your granny mckyle granin that's who